are you still excited by this because
that means you didn't see the last movie
opening tech scroll continues to bore
and delight everyone more talk about the
Senate the next thing you know this
franchise are gonna turn into The
Manchurian Candidate which is a great
movie when it's not called Star Wars the
third paragraph of this scroll is about
the exciting action of voting discount
CGI Cloud City it was no danger at all
bomb was timed to explode at the moment
of jinxing senator well you blew up
instead of hurt so I'd say that's pretty
successful citizens Allah please how
does one go from queen to senator do you
have to renounce your bloodlines claim
to the throne is senator actually a
higher office and queen to the society
I'm so confused
we're keepers of the Peace not soldiers
oh did the Jedi look out with sporadic
uprisings until this moment in time how
do they keep the peace with so few of
them if there aren't enough to go to war
that's like having a National Guard
based in Nebraska with 15 people in it
who can go to Florida if need be but are
powerless if anything happens later in
Texas the dark cloud everything let's
just go ahead and say it Yoda is useless
as a prophet also how does Palpatine
have such amazing control of the darker
side of the force that none of these
Jedi can sense it 3 feet away impossible
to see and yet future prophecy bull will
drive everything we do from here on yes
stop hologram
I think the Count Dooku is behind it
well then if you say so
he Count Dooku was once a Jedi he
couldn't assassinate anyone it's not in
his character did these assholes never
once run into a Jedi he went to the dark
side
why does everyone fret about training
someone like Anakin if that's the case
sure Darth Maul said something about
revealing ourselves to the Jedi but I
thought he was implying they'd been gone
a long time
not that they never existed he's just
returned from a border dispute on
anciano he and Anakin were able to take
care of that border dispute all by
themselves not only amazing but not
filmed to show us how that works
I haven't felt you this tense since
since we fell into that nest of gundarks
that sounds exciting let's watch that
instead of this just like a phone that
constantly rings Georgia enters the
picture to jangle your nerves Annie my
goodness you've grown
but you haven't well you guys are the
same age now
and he'll always be that little boy I
knew on Tatooine so let's have kids
together I hit the ship but they used a
decoy why did you wait until the ship
was deboarding to hit it we'll have to
try something more subtle this time Zam
why she covered the cameras I don't
think she liked me watching her yeah
would anybody especially someone who
basically led it first during the
introductions a minute ago
you'll using her as bait why not use
another decoy why not dressing dragged
in her bedroom while she sleeps on a
nondescript floor of this building
besides her senses aren't that attuned
my young apprentice and yours are just
how much bag talk is ob1 put up with
from this little throughout the years
because I'm betting it's way too much
just being around her again is
intoxicating good god man Anakin is
already out of control a guy needs to
bang a hooker fast you've made a
commitment to the Jedi Order a
commitment not easily broken and which
doesn't allow for the power of boners if
they know the exact floor and exact room
Padme is sleeping in why didn't they
just program this thing to fire missiles
into the room yeah yeah the assassins
felt like they needed to be more subtle
but do you think people wouldn't be able
to figure out this was foul play
the Chancellor doesn't appear to be
corrupt now here's something extremely
weird obi-wan jumps and crashes through
the window like a dick through blinds
and what is probably some tough ass
glass even if it has a small hole in it
it's amazing it doesn't fall to his
death right here this is something I'm
becoming a pass character and something
Anakin might more likely do since he's a
hormone based horndog of a Jedi right
now also obi-wan jumps out of window to
grab onto a probe sent to kill Padme
because he thinks the probe will lead
him to the person controlling it he
thinks he can interrogate the probe who
sent you bro
you'd also think a subtle device like
this might have a self-destruct button
in order to evade evidence and capture
but luckily for obi-wan this murder
probe is programmed to return to its
owner after a failed murder attempt I've
got a gun that can fire with utmost
accuracy but I'll shoot the probe and
let gravity decide this whoa wait what's
that is that my falling master in the
middle of all this craziness ex machina
to the rescue this is the equivalent of
thinking that if you jump at the last
minute in a falling elevator you'll be
safe
obi-wan finds the assassin because I
guess every question is answered with
the force but even with that the
assassin decided to fly in the general
direction of Obi Wan's fall just a
second ago even though she was way up
high earlier geez how did he survive
this the answer is just because whew
that's over time to take off my mask for
virtually no reason
I hate it when he does that you did the
exact same thing a minute ago do you
remember crashing through the glass
after a pink flying probe here's the
problem if you're going to explain he
survives these things and somehow knows
where's am ship is just because of the
force you're gonna have to do a better
job of relaying that message this is
some serious right here anakin
doesn't pull out his lightsaber and
infiltrate or crash this speeder
instantly what once Anakin does use his
lightsaber he's terrific Lee bad at
killing speeder pilots with it
this is more unbelievable than Harry
finding Peter in the world unity
festival crowd and spider-man the stupid
kid finding spider-man's mask in
spider-man 2 and Peter Parker finding
his engagement ring while falling off a
building in spider-man 3 also obi-wan
conveniently catches Anakin's lightsaber
but then sets it on the passenger seat
without care almost ensuring that will
go airborne or otherwise missing during
the ensuing aerial chase also I thought
anakin wanted to see where the ship went
where the assassin went and who she's
working for
instead he just went right back to let's
kill this asshole and doesn't seem at
least bit concerned about the other
knowledge this weapon is your life it
really isn't you can make more and there
are alternatives to fighting as we learn
from somebody else in the earlier
trilogy I forget who why do I get the
feeling you're going to be the death of
me not hilarious overly manipulated
foreshadowing you wanna buy some death
sticks what a creative name for a thing
you want to go home and rethink your
life my life this is the only time Jedi
Mind Tricks ever work once with a
stormtrooper in the first movie and with
this drug dealer in the fifth movie also
during this entire chase no one is
standing at the door to make sure the
assassin doesn't walk out obi-wan is
drinking definitely something a Jedi
does when hunting somebody down oh now I
know why obi-wan is drinking so that
there's a callback to the original Star
Wars in the Mos Eisley cantina and so
George Lucas can find an excuse to cut
off another limb also why didn't she
just shift into her other self or a
disguise and simply walk out tell us now
they don't even try to Jedi Mind Tricks
Am they just go the old fashioned Batman
and/or Jack Bauer route that was a
bounty hunter a cog there's no chance in
hell Jango knew where anyone was and
what time they'd be here just go right
to hell with that
by the way he had no problem jumping
after probes and to find death and
traffic a minute ago to find Sam
but this Django dude I will just wait
here and hope the dying dream Lincoln
tell us some stuff toxic dot it'll
probably be the only good shot this guy
ever gets off during these movies what
about Senator Amidala she will still
need protecting handle that will I
sensed he cared deeply about his mother
who didn't want to train him because of
that earlier but now I can't sense this
horny teenagers desire and will make him
the primary guard for army dollar
everything here would look beautiful it
didn't look like issue the boy has
exceptional skills but he still has much
to learn master somehow between the last
movie in this one obi-wan and the Jedi
Council have completely reversed their
roles on the idea of Anakin as a Jedi
too sure of themselves they are maybe
it's that constant fear leads to the
dark side tripe you've been preaching
this whole time that makes them more
confident than they should be the
prophecy is true your apprentice is the
only one who can bring the force back
into balance yeah about this prophecy is
there some sort of turmoil going on with
a Jedi need the force to come back into
balance if so what does Anakin need to
do to bring about that balance exists
there's absolutely no explanation for
this and it feels like it was put in the
script just to sound good it will be
your responsibility to take my place in
the Senate representative Binks well he
certainly is qualified I haven't worked
for a year to defeat the military
Creation Act to not be here when its
fate is decided I mean all is exposition
news says clunky is the opening crawl
which already talked about this vote for
which she wants to be present honey
laughter Amidala had the run-in with the
autonomous probe the previous night
she's allowed to walk around
unobstructed windows to her heart's
delight he's overly critical he never
listens where did this come from
you were just talking about making sure
she's safe and it turned into a diatribe
about how life's unfair to you it's not
fair Padme will not only ignore this
childishness but go on to enter a sexual
relationship with this whiny baby please
don't look at me like that
why not cuz it feels like you want to
play with your lightsaber your creepy
bastard
Saima lay well that is evil and creepy
and now I need a shower
Rose Byrne and Natalie Portman are not
my sister-wives in the sink don't do
anything without first consulting either
myself or the council especially
this Queen here you saw these kinds of
poison darts when you were prospecting
funny little cuts on the side to give it
away those analysis droids only four
was on symbol Oh I mean what this is a
library right and it looks like
everything is digital so why the need
for large stacks of blue everywhere um
the official subtitles here say that
r2d2 gave that cook robot raspberries
well I'll deal with the people that I
love you do not love her yet you haven't
even seen her in 10 years you have a
boner
that's it how does Jedi training not
include sex ed attachments for men so do
all the Jedi I just hope that all
potential Jedi in the universe are
created by that Shmi Skywalker method of
midi-chlorian pregnancy I'll tell you
how this romance has made even more
painful it has to start with Amidala
resisting Anakin for nearly the whole
movie before they can start lying around
in flowers and floaty ball practice
because I want to raised it from the
archive memory oh come on so they get to
straight just on the off chance someone
was looking for this planet for whatever
reason someone decided to release it
from the archives and why would anyone
be looking for this planet except when
someone finds a rare poisoned dart that
only the chef at a diner could recognize
also they removed the planet but they
didn't remove anything else that might
help someone locate it that gives you
like the opposite effect of what you're
trying to accomplish right might as well
put a neon sign there that said planet
removed for incriminating purposes but
Master Yoda who could empty information
from the archives that's impossible
isn't it yeah who could it be who has
the power around here I'm gonna blame
george w bush until we get to the bottom
of this barely are to navigate stairs
one by one very slowly but can catch up
to them no problem even though they
never stopped
I heard they even tried to amend the
Constitution so you could stay in office
she was a queen no right not an elected
official or does this planet just elect
people and call them queens the day we
stop believing democracy can work is the
day we lose it let's pray that day never
comes you will have a queen in this
world right isn't that a monarchy or are
you like the British monarchy where you
have a queen but she has no power
there it is r4 yep the planet we've
probably seen for many many parsecs
because it is a huge celestial body in
space I am just now acknowledging that I
see it you will be delighted to hear
that we are on schedule all these people
need to know is that obi-wan is a Jedi
and they just blabbed the whole evil
plan to him before making sure it's okay
to tell him I don't like sand it's
coarse and rough and irritating and it
gets everywhere never a more eloquent
word was spoken in order to woo a fine
woman here everything is soft and smooth
this line works also didn't even fools
just get here
rapid romances cooking rabbit we take
great pride in our combat education and
training programs we don't spend much
time on aiming practice an unaltered
clone for himself curious isn't it not
if you're trying to come up with the
origin story a Bubba Fett it isn't
everything in the background of this
shot is some bullsh people should be
ashamed of movie unintentionally
inspires Twilight do you get the sense
they walked into this meadow and like
back to the future to ordered this
background to show the scenery channel
we need a system where the politicians
sit down this romance and politics in
the same scene skip anakin pretends to
be hurt more seriously that he is she
falls forward and movie thinks that's
love movie misses its chance to insert
the lightsaber switching noise in this
scene no one apparently told Jane go
that a Jedi was coming because he left
his incriminated in the closet
completely on the open for anyone to see
though do their job well a whole army of
Ginga Fitz and somehow the bad guys are
gonna lose this thing they're about to
eat fruit with looking silverware and
I'm haunted by the kiss that you should
never have given me ladies and gentlemen
the poetry of George Herbert
Walker Lucas you're starting to become a
Jedi I'm I'm a senator sex is impossible
because senators have senator parts and
Jedi have Jedi parts we could have
accepted this love story and attack of
the clones if we could have seen Anakin
doing awesome Jedi throughout the movie
and Padme despite everything in the
world telling or not to decide it you
know what okay I need to go to this Jedi
and break off a piece and the story of
Luke and Leia's birth gets told without
all this arguing pleading and terrible
dialogue trying to make it so and I
would have cut about 20 minutes from the
movie
obi-wan has to give his report while
standing out in the middle of a
torrential downpour mmm Palpatine came
into power about ten years ago that Jedi
who supposedly ordered a clone army died
about 10 years ago and there's only one
guy was the kind of power to do all this
so could it be
mind if creation of this clone army we
could not see but instead of explaining
how that's possible
we dedicated many minutes to Amidala and
Anakin not having sex in other words
these movies tell you a lot about what
is happening but don't tell you the ins
and outs of why those things are and it
definitely isn't any ins and outs going
on in the bedroom either
you